احمد مجدي 25 سؤال لازم تجاوب عليهم بسرعه
من غير تفكير اكثر مكان تشعر فيه بالسعاده
اكثر قاسم مشترك بينك وبين زوجتك
من سنتين
العلاقه كلها كانت اربع سنين
الناس مفروض تنبسط بدي الارقام
دي خالص 2015
باحس نفسي اسعد كمخرج
اسوء شيء عملته في مراهقتك
ممثله تتمنى بطوله
[موسيقى]
همم موضوع نفسك تتناوله في عمل فني
اكثر شائع عنك ازعجتك
بالحقيقه انا مش بتاثر قوي بشعات
فعلا في واحده ازعجتني
استغربتها حاجه
كده خالص
مش مهم بقى طيب كم طولك 189 بعد الناس
بيوصفوك بالغريب دخل في اليوكا والبيئه
والطبيعه ونباتي وبتميل للسينما المستقله
وبتجمع الات موسيقيه قديمه بيزعجك عدم فهم
الناس الميوله
بفتح للناس افق جديده مع الوقت وكلنا
عندنا حاجات غريبه عادي
ااااه ضرني
تتمنى لو كان لك
بصراحه كثير قوي من اول الابيض واسود قبل
ما اتولد
في الغلط بس الحقيقه اللي جوايا دائما
بيغير يعني بشوف ادوار كتير لاصدقاء
والزملاء في نفسي
بقى العجز زميلك هينبسط همم
واحاول افتكر حاجه بجد كانت كبيره ومهمه
همم
يا ربي كانت حاجه مؤثره قوي اا
تت- تت-
بصي انا كل ما بشوف عمر الشريف بيقول انا
كان نفسي اكون في العصر ده بس ده اكثر
حاجه والحاجات بتاعت نجيب محفوظ يعني اي
حد بيشتغل على نجيب محفوظ بحيث ان انا
يعني نفسي ابقى مكانه واسامه انور اوكي
يعني بالنسبه لي في حاجات كثير قوي لما
باشوفها فعلا فعلا ما فيش حاجه معينه بس
بجد يعني الممثل جواه غيور شويه قلت انك
دخلت فيك علاقات كثير فاشله ندمان ولا
تعلمت
عليها في واحد في قرارات كثير الواحد
اخذها غلط اندفع فيها لكن في النهايه انا
شخص دائما
ابدا ابدا انا بحب العربيات وبحب
الموتوسيكلات وكده بس يمكن انت عشان بتشيل
الحب للموتوسيكلات في الحته دي بالضبط بس
الحقيقه هو الموتوسيكل دلوقتي هو احلى
حاجه في حياتي يعني السعاده
والمتعه اللي بتجيء لي من الموتوسيكل
بتخليني دائما ابقى حابب ان انا ابقى عليه
طول الوقت
بينفعل جدا ودي كانت الحاجه اللي عايز
امان وانا صغير
لحد لما جبت الموتوسيكل غصب عنه فاستسلم
الدرجه يعني اه ممكن ده يكون حصل وانا
سمعت انه حصل لكن الحقيقه اللي جاء لي كان
عظيم جدا الفان دايز بتاعتي كبرت جدا
والمسلسل بالنسبه لي نجح جدا ونجح في
تحقيق اللي انا كنت كل اللي كنت عايزه منه
همم اوكي يقال انك مهتم بتجسيد شخصيه
المخرج الراحل يوسف شاهين في عمل ليش
الحياه هو من اهم الايقونات السينما اي حد
يحلم انه يعملها ومره اتسالت السؤال ده
وقعت بلساني وقلت ان هي دي الشخصيه
الايقونيه الاكثر يعني ملحه جدا وما عنديش
اي تصور دي ممكن يحصل ازاي بس هي كان مجرد
مره وقعت بلساني وقلتها بس هي حقيقه
ايش بينقص الفنانه المصري انه
يسير ما بنشوف مشاركات بس ما حد بيوصل
لنجوميات عمر الشريف مثلا
صديق الاسد
مهمه جدا في السينما يعني في العالم ولكن
انا الحقيقه باشوف انه الشغل الممثل ممكن
يشتغل على انه يبقى نجم ممكن يشتغل على
انه يبقى ممثل كويس ممكن يشتغل انه يبقى
فنان
المشكله ان احنا عايزين نعمل كل حاجه
كممثلين ف همم لحد لما الواحد يستقر انه
فعلا ايه المجهود اللي هو عايز يعمله
اتجاه هيوصل اهو
طيب ليش في تعليقات كثير على موضوع ملابس
داليه وانك تلبس اشياء غريبه وكذا
كبيره بالضبط وده كانت يعني كانت لحظه
اللي هو مجنونه
بالضبط وهي كانت لحظه مجنونه جدا ودفنت
يعني اللي هي حاجه مكرونتش ثاني اه طبعا
بس هي ساعات الواحد لازم يجرب يعدي يعدي
الخطوط الحمراء وهو ما يعرفش اصلا فده
اللي حصل يعني
تريند بسبب البدله كانت حاجه صعبه شويه
كان يومين صعبين قوي
طيب شيء ما يعرف الناس عنك
[ضحك]
دي من من اصعب اللحظات اللي في حياتي يعني
او دقائق قليله يعني فاكر يعني كان اول
مره اقول كلمه الحقوني يعني كان همم كنت
باسمعها في الافلام والمصدقهاش بس كانت
فعلا تجربه صعبه جدا يعني ف همم كانت همم
ما وقفتش لا خالص كانت بالنسبه لي حاجه
خطاها وانا كنت راضي بطل الجمهوريه مثلا
على فكره عايز ياخذ السنه اللي بعديه يعني
اكثر نفسي
تسلعيه بدل ما تستري
مش عارف والله شقي شويه وباحب الباركور
وبحب اتحرك وباخذ حاجات شويه رزقي في في
القياده مثلا ما بقولش ده طبعا كثير
البس الخوذه
انا مركز جدا جدا بصراحه في شغل الفتره دي